hey it's Friday again already and it's
time for another movie retrospective
going back to the 1980s going back to a
DS werewolf movies oh yeah this is
actually one of the bit and you know I
say this as saying like I'm listen yeah
there's not like a [ __ ] ton of werewolf
movies I guess and there's really not
that many good ones I can maybe think of
four or five the one we're doing today
is one of them it is the howling kind of
an unappreciated Jim yeah from 1981 it
came out only was it two months before
or two months after an American worth in
London and it was after and it was
actually like a lot of you know yeah
interconnection between the people that
worked on it and stuff like that so we
get into that a little bit yeah bad date
when you were kid this was a I always
thought this is a lot more impressive
than American world were from London
there were more werewolves it was more
like a slasher flick it was more like
watching like Friday the 13th or
something I liked it yeah it's like the
tone of the movies is kind of different
like I'll kind of get into that I'm not
really sure which one I like better they
both have their charms like I said
really the only other good werewolf
movies I can think of modern era Dog
Soldiers awesome Ginger Snaps was pretty
good company of wolves I knew those oh
yeah you know you would actually
probably really like Dog Soldiers yeah
probably would that came out in 2009
[Music]
somewhere like that it's it's really
good British it's it's but it's a really
good movie like this werewolves in it
were really scary but the howling
actually came out in 1981 um like I said
it seems like it gets overshadowed a
little bit by an american werewolf in
london but in many ways I think it's
just as good it's actually based on a
novel by Gary Brandon er although the
novel is not really the same they they
changed a lot of things this was
directed by Joe Dante who obviously did
piranha the success of this movie
actually led to him getting gremlins so
you know that's how that whole thing
went this movie it's almost
like like he said it has like a sleazier
vibe than American Werewolf in London um
it's also funny but not in the same way
that American world I mean American
Werewolf in London is as scary moments
but it's obviously a horror comedy this
one the humor is a lot more sardonic
satirical it's almost kind of like a
satirical kind of werewolf movie and
there's like a lot of in jokes and like
references in there for people who are
horror fans
yeah lots of callbacks a lon chaney and
other werewolf movies and stuff yeah
there's like a really lot of Easter eggs
in this because Joe Dante is like a huge
horror fan and he always kind of did
that like would putting cameos and like
what he named characters and stuff like
that chili yeah well yeah like little
cans of wolf brand chili and stuff but
yeah I'll get into that a little bit
more later too but basically the whole
setup of the movie and I'll get a little
bit into how it differs from the book to
but the whole setup of the movie has to
do with a noose newscaster and she is
played by Dee Wallace and she is being
stalked by a serial killer
yeah Dee Wallace's she's the girl from
frighteners the the the older woman who
was Johnny Bartlett's girlfriend yeah
yeah she was also the mom in et yeah um
but yeah so she was in a [ __ ] ton of
genre you see back in the day but yeah
so she's being she's been being stalked
by the serial killer named Eddie Quist
so the police have been utilizing her
like to catch him right so she like
agrees to meet him like in this sleazy
porno theater and you know the police
end up shooting him but she sees him
during this really traumatic episode but
then the episode is so traumatic like
the attack on her that she kind of gets
sort of partially I mean like she can't
even she can't remember what he looked
like she can't remember anything like
that
so as a you know to kind of get over the
trauma of this whole incident her
psychiatrist who was played by Patrick
McNee yeah yeah he's in a [ __ ] ton of
movies too sends her and her husband
Bill who is actually played by her
real-life husband in this movie at least
at the time I don't know if they're
still married or not
but they go to this retreat out in the
woods because it was you know 1981 y'all
and it was California so you know
anything that was wrong with you they
could send you out in the woods and run
around for a little while and it would
cure all the tails like they did in all
the horror movies no I do draw but what
was the other one by the brood yeah the
brood same kind of thing where they send
you to the kind of this forest retreat
and it's supposed to like you know be
psychologically good for you because
apparently that's what's wrong with
everybody and also that seemed like yeah
that was like a friend of a new age Age
of Aquarius oh yeah where they'd always
like send you out in the woods so you
could like run around and like let let
loose your inner yes always I don't know
child and all that to see yes so she had
somebody selling those things to people
- yeah I don't think that well there's
some about this when they start getting
into this element of the movie it also
always reminded me of the movie the
island which we did a another yeah you
said that while we were remind yeah that
a group of pirates and a group of
werewolves in the wilderness kind of
seemed a lot alike yeah the same
situation that was a kid yeah and the
movies the way they were filmed it kind
of hit a similar tone in a way I just
yeah I think we should say and you're
from that period in my childhood yeah
but so like they go to this mountain
retreat and it's not even a spoiler and
I'm sure it will not be a surprise to
anyone that this place which is called
the colony is all werewolf they're all
they're all werewolves but they're an
interesting thing about this it seems
like and I don't know I'm pretty sure
this pros probably the first werewolf
movie to do this because it seemed like
most werewolf movies prior to this one
and even American Werewolf in London had
this - they kind of took the trope from
the universal Wolfman where the Wolfman
like the whole plot of the story was you
know this poor guy he's just wandering
around the Moors or whatever he gets
bitten by a wolf and then it's like a
tragedy because he like turns into a
wolf he's killing people and he doesn't
mean to it's like a Jekyll and Hyde type
thing although not quite because
Jacqueline
I did that [ __ ] deliberately but so they
all kind of had that plot but the
interesting thing about the howling and
they don't go super into it they don't
beat a dead horse about it or anything
like that but kind of the background
theme of the whole story is that there's
that werewolves are real they exist they
didn't have to be any full moon or any
of that [ __ ] they're just
shapeshifters they can pretty much wolf
out whenever they want to but then
there's like two factions of werewolves
like some of them are living out in this
colony they're raising cattle to eat so
that they don't have to eat people but
there are some like defectors like in
the group that are like no we still want
to be werewolves like the old days and
go out and like tear people's heads off
and [ __ ] like that so there's like a so
there's like a thing between these two
groups of werewolves where we just want
to be you know some of the like werewolf
pride I guess you could say like someone
were like yeah we want to kill people
that's what we do and then other ones
are like no we need to learn to live
with people and not hurt them and but
still be werewolves you know yeah and
then there's always like an observer
like some kind of a doctor or professor
yeah actually over the group like yeah
it's just man letting out his primal
self yeah that was kind of like what
we're reminded me of the island because
they had that what was he he was a
sociologist yet saying they know these
are real men the way these pirates are
they're acting as real men you know that
this is the way people are supposed to
be but yeah that's it's kind of the same
thing as this because the psychiatrist
who actually sends Dee Wallace and her
husband off to the colony is he's not a
werewolf is he like he's just kind of
like the werewolf overseas oversea right
he's the one that's like trying to
encourage them yes it's fine to be
werewolves great of psychotherapy but
don't like kill people about it or
anything you know what I mean like I
said it's not they don't like go super
into it there's really only a couple
scenes where that's mentioned but it's
kind of cool because it's sort of this
underlying kind of thing there's also a
really really heavy undercurrent of sex
in this movie like sex and violence like
intertwined you know there's the very
very probably one of the most famous
scenes in the movie other than the
transformation scene is the werewolf sex
scene between Dee Wallace's house
and the hot lady werewolf yeah that I
had a crush on that girl since I was
little boy I don't I think everyone did
male or female yeah there was something
sexy about her she was like a gothy
gypsy ish looking Native American BDSM
plus you get to see Bush
you get seat it's ambush yeah and she
turns into a werewolf yeah and
simultaneously boners popped up all over
the Internet
I think actually I think that actress is
sadly passed away but she was actually
was really really hot in this movie and
so she was one of the ones that he was
like yeah I'm proud to be a werewolf and
so I don't wanted like you know so so
there was that whole thing and and there
was the whole thing - about the serial
killer at the beginning Eddie Quist who
like I said not not really a spoiler he
turns out to be a world
- Brooke but um his whole thing was when
he's at the very beginning when he's um
you know kind of stalking Dee Wallace's
character
I mean she's watching a video in a one
of those yucky porn booths like they
used to have back in the day before we
had the internet you know sad [ __ ] can
you imagine germs was pressed yeah you
wouldn't be able to watch anything you'd
have to go in there like a full body
[ __ ] plastic suiters imagine if you
were to dude they had to clean up the
that's what I mean that you could not
pay me enough to do that job I'm sorry
he really couldn't really can 70s and 82
the nasty time it was just like dirty a
dirty decade and then it was funny cuz
you you referred back to uh Jekyll and
Hyde yeah they had to be talking about
cocaine there had to be a direct
reference to coke yes we're book fiend
is yeah he's normal and they snorts up
and he goes out he goes to the bar
chases women an accident ass cuz it
makes you [ __ ] yeah I mean it has to
be repaired which explains the entire
decade of the 80s well no I
Jekyll and Hyde wasn't it wasn't the
1980s - no I said about okay yeah yeah
but they knew that that was 1807 yeah
yeah they were playing with it back then
that whoever wrote that must have been
well it was legal back then yeah he must
have been a coke freak yeah I have
actually heard some
because he have a doctor who's taking
something and going out at night and
being very different yeah normally is
that's how I am is a dentist getting
into his damn cocaine stash because they
used it to numb - yeah and then going
out chase of hookers yeah that's what
they're talking about anyway yeah like I
said well and like I said the whole
werewolf mythos is essentially like it
yeah it's like the duality of man type
right and like I said there that so
that's letting it ride we're gonna let
it ride so that's why I kind of like
that this almost like blatantly made
that not really blatantly because it's
just a subtext really but just kind of
made that more obvious maybe or maybe
like what enlarge the scope a little bit
its cushion are not just talking about
one person and he gets bitten by a
werewolf and now he's killing people he
loves and he can't control it and isn't
that sad
you're actually talking about people who
are where'll to like being werewolves
and how do we deal with that in modern
society type of thing and like I said
that's kind of a cool subtext and I
don't really think that any werewolf
movie had explored that angle of it
prior to this no they were doing what
you normally would do in the in the
vampire genre right so you know later on
they got it with the underworld series
that's what they're talking yeah it's
similar kind of thing but I think a lot
of the idea like kind of came from this
I don't know how much but I haven't read
the book I've heard the book is not very
good um but you know I don't know I
haven't read it so I'm not gonna say but
well we know the sequel to this isn't
very good
none of the sequels are any good
couldn't get through it we're just like
ah I saw the apart - which was what -
call your sister is a werewolf which you
already know it's gonna suck from that
come up from that parenthetical title
there is that what was called I thought
yeah open - it's not wolf howling - what
did I do yeah the howling - : your
sister is a werewolf
no [ __ ] those name of it yes I keep
thinking Wolfen because Wolfen was the
sucky werewolf yeah Wolfman came out the
same year as this yes I saw it a million
times on cable but I don't remember a
single goddamn thing about it very
generic from what I remember I almost
liked it again I would like to see it
again too because I don't remember
anything about it it might it might be
good I remember liking it at the time
you're older you might like it better
yeah I can't people I didn't really like
it at the time which was the original or
the remake a remake ok saw it later and
the remake it was better than I
remembered it yeah yeah we have actually
we found that like a few times this and
actually the howling I saw a lot on
cable back in the day but when we
watched it it's on shudder yeah and it
is it was actually much better than the
cat people is basically a werewolf story
it's yes similar it's just a cat same
same type of thing now let's talk a
little bit about the special effects in
this which are actually quite amazing
now Rick Baker was initially supposed to
do the special effects for this but then
he went and did American Werewolf in
London and the very famous daylight
transformation scene which people still
talk about to this day cuz it still
looks amazing yeah
now his understudy Rob poutine ended up
doing the howling now obviously he also
went on to do the thing and went on to
do many other movies so he's no slouch
he was only like 20 or 21 when he did
this movie and I have to say the
transformation of Eddie Quist into the
werewolf is still it still looks pretty
goddamn good I think yes it could be
hard to beat death practical effects
yeah and I mean how they did they have
like all these latex applications on the
actors face and like they had all these
like air bladders like underneath it so
it looked like his the front of his face
was coming out and like all the things
coming out of his hands and stuff it's
not done like in full day you know like
an American Werewolf in London is it's
done kind of in darkness but still they
have close-ups on the face and it's like
kind of all deforming and [ __ ] and you
can tell the dude is still in there so I
think it still looks almost as good
I mean I'm gonna say 95% as good as the
American world from London one I think
and I also think that because in
American Werewolf
the when he was in when David Naughton
was in like werewolf mode he actually
just looked like a real big wolf right
now in this one they look more like a
werewolf it looks like a bag eatle yeah
like a big bipedal dude that's like a
wolf with like big long ears and a big
you know so with the wolf feet yeah and
they're like eating stay
on their toes and stuff like that which
that was a kind of a cool detail and I'm
glad they did that and sometimes they
used like cartoon animation for that
yeah times it was it was practical
effects sometimes it was our animation
they just depended on the shot
I thought it was effective yeah with
that kind of stuff with the practical
effect I kind of prefer to CG
a lot of the times it depends it depends
on the movie yeah because it does look
like it's there yeah stuff doesn't look
like it's really there doesn't doesn't
look like it has any weight that is the
main problem that I have with CGI we saw
venom the other day and venom looked
great but none of that stuff looked real
to me it looked like it was massive I
don't mind it so much like in a fantasy
type setting or something like that but
when you're doing something that's
supposed to be real like you know a
werewolf monster that's like set you
know when it's like sitting the modern
day when it's not like in a fantasy or
like a sci-fi type I don't have to show
it much and yeah just don't show it I
mean [ __ ] like I said as far as I know
his first practical effects go you never
gonna be alien you're never gonna be an
American Werewolf in London that [ __ ]
was there one yeah it doesn't date right
because they're not using some CGI that
in 20 years is gonna look like a [ __ ]
cut scene from a [ __ ] ass maybe you
better you know the predator yeah it
looked okay but that CGI super tall big
predator thing it just didn't look real
I knew that that wasn't there yeah not
not in the year and like I said I'm not
like a total you know I'm not one of
those total like old B Lagoon this is
yeah but I think it looks better when
it's just used to enhance something
that's really there rather than just
creating monsters and characters less
than that big old predator yeah or scene
close-ups and different camera angles to
make him appear much bigger than he was
I didn't actually have to see that thing
standing next to a car you know because
he didn't look real to me that's what I
mean it's it's better when it's and I
think I've said this before but I think
it's better when it's judiciously I'm
Ryan
so you know and like I said when you see
an American Werewolf in London when you
see the howling which were made in
nineteen [ __ ] 81 and your werewolf
looks better than a werewolf movie that
perhaps was made a year or two ago
that's a problem um you know it's not a
problem for
movies back then because they knew what
the [ __ ] they were doing but it's a
little bit of a problem for now and it's
like I don't know if I'm sure they'll
probably resolve it at some point but
CGI just it never looks real to me it
just it always looked well like a video
game or a cartoon or something took a
certain amount of talent and you had to
have young guys who are willing to work
long hours to get practical effects
right and and the thing that you can see
they didn't always get it right there
was some problems in oh yeah
the hair on the hair on them sometimes
looked a little bit too long for me yeah
they should have trimmed the hair down
you know me it was long wolves don't
have hair like that yeah but it looked
good I mean it's obviously something
that's really there yeah you know right
so in that way it's like a way to look
better and it is a lot more menacing
I think werewolf is a lot more menacing
if it's like a dude in a suit than if
it's like a CGI monster because all I
can think of is when they were shooting
this the girl was like oh no a werewolf
nothing with like maybe a tennis ball
like it's a great it's great or
something so she knew where to look
that's like so that's the only thing I
can think of it's you know one of those
shots of that big werewolf I had to ask
us is that an animatronic or is there a
man in that and you said there's a man
in that I'm looking at yeah some of it
he looked too long they cut back and
forth yeah they had a few animatronic
animatronic creatures you know that
moved it was the same with American
Werewolf in London but some of it was
like I said latex applications and they
put things underneath it so it like
would bubble out and stuff like that so
you know it's a pretty effective it's if
it's fooling you if you're not really
sure if there's a man or not in it right
yeah I mean it and that's exactly my
point
and honestly like I said other than
American Werewolf in London which is
kind of like the gold standard for 80s
werewolf transformations this is a very
very very close second and like I said
it's Rob butene he did the thing which
the effects and that obviously are some
of the best ever done
so he's it's not that far off and for
someone so young but and another thing I
wanted to talk about too is that there's
a [ __ ] ton of like cute little because
like I said this does have some humor in
it but it's very subtle humor it's very
satirical a lot of it is like
references almost every single character
in this movie is named after a director
of aware of an old werewolf movie and
also there are some like camp cameos
there's one point there's one part where
Dee Wallace is in the phone booth and
she leaves the film this is a guy
standing outside like waiting for the
phone booth and that's Roger Corman and
Roger Corman was also the one who taught
Joe Dante like you know I mean so Joe
Dante was like his student so he was
kind of making her Maj they're in the
occult bookstore scene forrest ackerman
obviously Famous Monsters of Filmland
makes a cameo appearance also the guy
that's in there the actor I can't
remember his name is but um his
character name is Walter Paisley and
that was the same name as the part he
played in Roger Corman's a bucket of
blood so he's playing like the same guy
like it was the same universe
another thing I want to talk about too
is this this movie is kind of like ahead
of its time
I feel like it's like almost like a meta
horror in the scream type of vein but
many many years before scream you know
what I mean because it's very self
referential and also the end part where
I'm like I said I'm you know it's like
yes boiler alert and stuff like that but
it's like I'm not gonna worry about it
so so the end okay because I just want
to talk about this the end part where
the main character you know Dee
Wallace's character she is a TV reporter
and goes on TV and wants to warn the
world about the werewolves so you know
she werewolves out in on live television
and then they show like all these people
the TV ions go would over especially
yeah yeah so it was almost like making
like a sly like media comes even back in
1981 they were talking about how TV had
to like resort to these cheap ass
tactics to get people to watch it and
stuff like that which I thought was very
funny and I was like that's really
something that I guess that's but since
time immemorial they've been like making
what was funny about that is that my
memory
of that of that last scene was nothing
like way it really looked I remembered
her transforming into like a really
pretty werewolf but when I saw it it
didn't look like that at all she just
looked like a were any other werewolf in
it actually looked like a hand puppet to
me I think it might have been a
miniature was it uh I don't know
actually didn't look like it was
full-sized it looked like maybe it was a
small hand puppet of a werewolf
you know thought about don't want to
want to sound like an [ __ ] but I'm
not sure that was a full-sized werewolf
costume that's what happened see girls
don't know werewolves they just turned
into werewolf puppet I think it wasn't
around you know talking about a
miniature desk I don't seem to be full
size to me I didn't notice that size
everything I don't know if that was just
you and you're a really drunkard yeah I
was drinking or if you drink attention
but the eyes on it didn't look like a
human eyes looking through a mask it
looked like glass beads and the way it
moved look like somebody with a hand
puppet now I'm gonna have to go watch
again I don't think it was a fool
because I don't remember I don't
remember being it obvious to me that
it's like ooh what I saw is like puppet
show yeah I said that's a muppet
[Laughter]
sometimes well yeah I nature's they use
miniatures a lot most of the time you
can tell and especially you know if
you're listening in the thing and the
very final end when they're fighting a
huge thing that was underneath the
ground mm-hmm oh yeah miniature okay but
I never I never noticed that though yeah
even all the little barrels to ground
everything yeah I never noticed it but
that's what it is they use lots of
managers they did but sometimes you
could tell and sometimes you couldn't
because sometimes when I go back and
like watch some stuff and then later on
I learned it was a miniature yeah like
remember when we were doing the skate
from New York and they said yeah we
built the whole city of New York and we
put like all these [ __ ] this glow
tape and [ __ ] around it so it would look
like and I was like oh my god I never
had a skyline with the water and
everything it's it's a miniature on in a
garage with a wet floor yeah from the
right I never went over the right
lighting
until I saw that document my mind was
balloon yeah doesn't look like a
miniature but it is it really really
doesn't
but like I said you know there's some
obviously let's talk about Superman
Logan's Run you know stuff like that
have miniatures that are obviously
miniatures yeah but look at Ron's bad
about yeah it is yeah but um you know
when a miniature is done well you
shouldn't be able to tell it should be
seamless and I've escaped from New York
was obviously very seamless and like I
said I don't really I don't remember the
the scene that you're talking about now
I'm gonna have to go back and watch
again I shot the world because yeah we
theater yeah well when I saw it yeah
they have the the the newscasters behind
the table yeah the table look miniature
and to me the werewolf look miniature
look like a hand puppet it could have
been yeah I have to see it again I was
drunk yeah that's what I made it just me
baby just imagine that yeah also yes I
was running with kulikov I'm halfway
there
holy crap we got a lot of episodes to do
to film today too so there well just two
more anymore we're trying to get ahead
cuz you know Halloween show and all this
other kind of stuff I got which reminds
me that's something that I was gonna
mention okay well while we're still
talking about the howling yeah they did
do a couple scenes in stop-motion
animation and a couple scenes in like
traditional cel animation then looks so
good they just did it for budgets but
honestly nowadays when you watch it
nowadays it's almost like it was just an
artistic choice yeah I kind of feel like
cuz the two scenes where they do it is
just like very very brief and I'm always
kind of like you arty like not you know
I didn't think they were trying to get
it to look real but I guess they were at
the time of the three werewolves were
trying to tear into that car looks
pretty cool those are pretty big where
yes I don't know if they were people in
costumes or animatronics I think you've
heard an animatronic monster yeah it
looked big yeah I mean the car was small
it was a what tier seven or something a
little convertible you would know I
wouldn't live oh yeah there's a Mazda is
what it was I think there's a Mazda rx-7
it's a big comment on that in the in the
movie what kind of car was it yeah you
can afford a Mazda the guy said that's
right that's what I was thinking I think
they look like an rx-7 well they little
one of the old road Reese yeah I'd like
some stuff but they were small yeah but
besides the Miata but I actually do
really like like I said from everything
I've heard I've seen the second movie of
this howling too
your sisters wearable um I saw it on
cable back in the day and remember just
being like whatever and then we tried to
watch it again
it was on to be I think we got about 20
minutes in and we're just like this is
painful painful wieners
I remember this equals two scatters
being pretty good but I tried to watch
scanners too and I just couldn't get
through it we're like seeing it through
those nostalgia glasses see but that's
why it's good to revisit some big stuff
scanners scene scanners get transfers
yeah a transfer student installs a glass
you thought that was so awesome yeah
when I was a kid a mass transit was a
good one saw it again and I'm like this
is [ __ ] [ __ ] here it really was I'm
good at following movies but I'm saying
they're gonna [ __ ] is going on
did someone dose me I don't know what's
happening and I like David Lynch movies
for [ __ ] sake it was very bad but but
yeah so from what I've heard all there
so I didn't even bother with any of the
rest of the sequels apparently they were
like um roughly a million of them who
knows maybe they get better but not from
what I've heard no they get worse I've
heard thrown around yeah you know how
about all the Amityville sequels were
like however 50 bajillion of those there
were there like these ones are worse
I'll tell you what though the only
series where they seem to get better as
they go with phantasm phantasm kicked
ass it really did it got better with
each film we're gonna have to review
three four and five because we watched
all those like right and close proximity
to look and we've already done one and
two so that's my favorite series for
horror I think it's the most
consistently good I feel like it yeah
well Evil Dead 2 like all of like evil
they're all evil do all the evil desert
it's up there with Evil Dead TV shows I
think I'm gonna nod just cuz it's
weirder weirder more more of an original
premise yeah that's my favorite thing
about phantasm it sounds [ __ ] weird
it is and it doesn't mean they're just
like oh they're made with love
yeah just like look out where the [ __ ]
is we don't even care yeah yeah there's
balls together sworps whatever yeah but
yeah so like I said if you haven't seen
the howling cuz like I said it gets
overshadowed a lot because it came out
pretty much the same
I'm as an American Werewolf in London
and they're they're very different
movies though like I said it's it's
funny but not funny the way American
Werewolf in London is funny it's more of
a straight-up horror movie it's kind of
like like I said it's self referential
so it's sort of like scream but it also
has some old-school tropes like it has
like an old organ type of theme going on
too and they're like the old monster
movies and so it has more has more of a
sleazy vibes darker I'm gonna put over
here I'm gonna put it up there with the
island good good movies like Videodrome
and the brood you know in that in that
vein yeah I like you know I liked it and
it was actually like I said I hadn't
seen it probably since the mid 80s and
seeing it again it was like really I was
like wow this is like way it doesn't
like much better than I remember it is
the hand even though it's quite
different than the hand yeah I love the
hand and was awesome that movie freaked
me out
and again man that movie freak me the
[ __ ] out bag and dismemberment like
always gonna get okay I mean Michael
Caine like no [ __ ] case Michael
[ __ ] Kane is another one just one gin
and tonic away from whipping your
[ __ ] ass he definitely seems like a
barely contained or easy person who's
[ __ ] nut but that's what makes him
awesome though is because you can tell
it's just like seething of it any moment
and who knows when it's gonna happen
you might be there to witness any moment
he's busts out with it but yeah so
before before we end up the review this
is gonna be the first review that's
gonna go before our new experimental
show I know that I said that we were
gonna wait until we got to $1,000 on
patreon before we start a third show
blah blah blah get time for that though
I guess after that is that well and
honestly this was something that we just
came up with like a few days ago he came
up with it and I was like yeah it's a
good idea let's do that [ __ ] like now so
what we decided to do since as we
mentioned on the show before we got a
subscription to the AMC Stubbs a list
program where you pay 20 bucks Mon cc3
you can see three movies a week at the
theater so he's like well why don't we
just turn that into a third show like
review new movies we'll just go see
three movies will do little caps
reviews of them and then edit them
together at the end of the weekend will
be like our week at the movies type of
show so I was like that is an excellent
idea since we're already going to the
movies anyways we'll make that [ __ ] work
for us we'll write that [ __ ] off as a
business we just would you know we would
do it there you do a third thing about
it so now what I'm gonna try to do I'm
gonna try and put them up on Sundays cuz
like the end of the week slash beginning
of the week and you know our little
movie watching thing like renews on
Friday so we usually go in the midweek
and see three movies and then I can have
the weekend to cut it all together and
then I'll put it them up on Sunday so
this one that's going to come up on
Sunday we're doing the three movies that
we saw this week we did have some
technical issues with we took video
because we've been taking like little
intro video but like before we go into
the movie and then we come out and sit
outside of the theater and talk about
what we thought of the movie like our
impressions so we did that for all the
movies except when we went to see
Hellfest we actually recorded our little
thoughts afterward and then we had
technical issues and we get it out and
we lost it yeah so I said okay so what
we'll do then I said we'll just do a
little capsule review of Hellfest you
know just at home cuz we still remember
it was just a couple days ago and then
I'll just put that in with the rest of
the stuff and that's how it goes but
we're gonna call it the 13 o'clock
matinee with Tom and Jenny yeah or
something like that yeah or something
like that you know it's just gonna be
like a little build maybe like you know
15 20 minutes show just us talking about
like going to the movie and talk about
what we thought of it like after we come
out of the theater and stuff like that
yeah just give you guys a heads up on
what's out there right now yeah what you
might want to spend money on and say
won't do don't spend money on some of
these might be losers and obviously you
know we can see three movies a week we
can't see every [ __ ] movie in the
world but it'll mostly I mean obviously
we mostly stick with horror sci-fi
thriller
yeah so we'll be doing that like I said
Hellfest is one of the ones we did last
week do you want to tell them the other
ones are we gonna be surprised yeah
so that'll be something that you guys
can look forward to hopefully you will
enjoy
well I'm not gonna do an audio version
I'll just do a video for the for YouTube
yeah cuz I don't see the point of doing
an audio version of us sitting in a
movie theater
I like talking about a movie because no
one could see it if they were just
listening on audio yeah so anyway that
will wrap up our latest movie
retrospective and remember as I say
every time if you'd like to financially
support the show you go to our patreon
page at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation please send your scary
stories either true or fictional to
grave cake at gmail.com you only have a
couple more days because we're gonna
record the Halloween episode on the 19th
to 20th 21st somewhere around there so
just to be safe get it to me before the
19th if you want it read on the show
already got a [ __ ] ton and there's like
a lot of really good ones this is gonna
be like a really fun show we're gonna
have some guests and stuff too so if you
want to get him in then hurry up and do
that in the next week and I think that
will do it for our movie or
retrospective right yeah all right we
will see you next time bye